face à la belgique martinique et raphaël
varane et ses coéquipiers vont tenter de
se hisser en finale pour la troisième
fois de leur histoire avec 73 rencontres
jouées la belgique demeure de loin
l'adversaire privilégié de l'équipe de
france belgique c'est une très bonne
équipe
c'est une équipe qui est jeune qui a un
si jeune mais qui arrive aussi à
maturité donc c'est une équipe qui est
assez complète qui est bien en place qui
est solide donc on sait on sait quel
adversaire on aura et on sait que ce
sera difficile et qu'il va falloir
réussir une grosse performance pour
accéder à la finale
c'est certainement la génération la plus
douée du football belge
les diables rouges comptent deux
antilles et dans leur groupe le milieu
de terrain martinique et axel weeds elle
est le champion du monde 98 thierry
henry l'ancien attaquant des bleus et
entraîneur adjoint de la formation belge
henry va retrouver sur le banc adverse
son ancien capitaine didier deschamps
une situation difficile pas facile pour
lui parce que ça arrive des fois en club
quand vous êtes dans un club étranger
vous revenez jouer contre un club
français en l'occurrence vous faites
partie de l'équipe ennemie là c'est
encore un cran au dessus puisqu'il va
être sur le banc et en face il ya son
pays sa nation ce derby s'annonce comme
un véritable choc
il aura une saveur toute particulière
dans ces deux nations se connaissent